we begin with this president Trump says
tax reform is a Christmas gift for
America
he brought congressional Republicans to
the White House to celebrate passing the
historic GOP measure and flex the
party's muscle the bill will cut taxes
for most taxpayers next year but
corporations and the wealthy will get
the biggest benefit it slashes the
corporate rate from 35 to 21 percent
major Garrett is at the White House
where the president shared the spotlight
yesterday a major good morning good
morning as this massive tax cut was
moving through the legislative process
top advisors to President Trump begged
him to give Senate Republican leader
Mitch McConnell the credit they said he
deserves for holding Republicans
together all year on the Trump agenda
save for one failure a conspicuous one
on health care will win the tax bill
passed the president finally relented
creating a rare portrait of Republican
unity it's always a lot of fun when you
win President Trump made the most of his
first big legislative win so he invited
nearly 200 congressional Republicans to
celebrate tax cuts and him mr. president
thank you for getting us over the finish
line you're one heck of a leader earlier
the president praised Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell with whom he's
had a frosty relationship all year
writing on Twitter he could not have
asked for a better or more talented
partner McConnell returned the praise
but there's been a year of extraordinary
accomplishment for the Trump
administration meeting for the ninth
time this year with his cabinet mr.
Trump asked housing secretary ben Carson
to say a prayer something we'll ask you
to say grace Carson called the president
and his colleagues a blessing we thank
you for four months the White House is
pitched tax cuts as a boon for the
middle class the bill now passed mr.
Trump admitted corporations are the big
winners our plan also lowers the tax on
American business that's probably the
biggest factor in this plan the bill
also doubles the standard deduction for
individuals and families and cuts the
individual tax rate for the highest
earners from thirty nine point six
percent to 37 percent Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer said Republicans
failed the middle
class there are only two places where
America's popping champagne the White
House and the corporate boardrooms this
is a big win for the White House but in
the very near future the president will
need Democrats not one of whom voted for
this tax reform legislation if he hopes
to achieve victories on children's
health insurance infrastructure welfare
reform or even military spending now the
individual tax rate cuts in this bill
are set to expire in 2025 but the
business and corporate tax cuts are
permanent and Anthony some employees are
already seeing benefits either in terms
of year-end bonuses or promised higher
wages yes they are major thanks major
Garrett